it's important to remember to cover the
basics hey everyone we have reached the
point the month where I plan to talk
about LGBTQ representation which does
mean that to start we are going to swap
out the look while I sort of reiterate
for anyone new in case you did not
already know I do have a dog in this
race
I am gender-fluid that does put me in as
part of the lgbtq+ community and a part
of why I talk about it now with that
kind of all set it occurred to me
recently that in these videos up until
this point I've sort of skipped over
something that I really should have
addressed by now and that is why just
representation even matter at all you
see every video on this topic that I've
done up to this point has been operating
on the basis of that representation is
important and that the people watching
these videos already accept that as a
fact well I'm glad I didn't bog down
earlier videos in explaining why
representation matters every single time
I talk about it I do want to do that as
the primary focus here because while it
may be incredibly obvious to me that
representation is important it's
actually pretty presumptuous of me to
treat that as a given for anybody else
who may be watching this now trying to
lay it out in a relatable way has
actually proven to be a bit harder than
I was expecting because if you're
someone who has never felt
underrepresented in pop culture it's
really difficult to explain that
experience to you I really couldn't come
up with a proper common frame of
reference because I could rant any
thought experiment I want I could devise
a million okay so imagine that type
scenarios but that
doesn't really make the point that kind
of thing I mean they can work on a
one-on-one conversation where I can
really tailor a thought experiment to a
specific person who I'm talking to be
sure that I'm linking it to something I
know they relate to but trying to do it
as a broad universal point of reference
yeah yeah I couldn't find one
regardless I'm gonna try and do this to
the best of my ability and inevitably I
am going to still end up leaning on some
of those aforementioned
thought experiments because I mean I'm
only so creative and sometimes I need a
crutch even if I know it's not as sturdy
as I would like it to be so the first
thing that I want to clear up is what I
often see as a misunderstanding or
misrepresentation of why groups like the
lgbtq+ lgbtq+ community even seeks
greater level of representation at all
because one of the standard rebuttals is
something along along the lines of what
you can't relate to a character if
they're not exactly like you or
sometimes a variant like I can relate to
gay characters why can't you relate to
straight ones and the issue of
representation is not a matter of being
incapable of relating to characters that
are different from ourselves
a well written and perform character can
be relatable to audiences who don't
share many if any of that characters
specific traits when it comes to things
like gender or race sexuality religious
beliefs home life etcetera etc of course
we get so early to these characters if
they're well done anybody can otherwise
there'd be no setting outside of the
present because anything set in the past
the future or some fantastical imagined
world would be unrelatable so please
banish from your mind the idea that
LGBTQ plus people flat out can't
relate to cisgender heterosexual
characters because that's not the issue
at hand and to claim that it is or
pretend like it is misses the point and
derail the conversation the thing is
even if you are part of the
statistically most represented group in
American entertainment which is to say
white male heterosexual cisgender
there's probably been a movie or a show
somewhere along the line that spoke to
you or your experience in a way that
other films didn't and I can happen for
any number of reasons let's take a film
setting when cities that are
infrequently depicted get a proper
highlight in a film it's pretty common
for that film to become something of a
point of pride for that city there's a
reason Philadelphia has a statue of the
fictional character Rocky Balboa and
Detroit has such a deep love for Robocop
heck it does not need to be in any way a
positive depiction of the city I mean
the city of Fargo knows North Dakota has
props from the dark comedy that shares
its name in its towns visitor center
including the wood chipper that was used
to grind up Steve Buscemi and it's not
that these paint a particularly
flattering or pandering images of these
plays but the locations are important to
the story the residents of the real
place feel that the film's captured some
truth about their home and the film's
then become important to those people
who live there you can actually see a
similar phenomenon when it comes to
occupations even ones that are depicted
frequently on film getting the depiction
of a character's job wrong is a
distraction for anyone who knows what
the reality of that line of work is my
my mother who was a nurse for her entire
professional life couldn't get into the
TV show house and a big part of that was
well that's about how hospitals work and
she knew that so I kept pulling her
out of the stories but it's not just
getting details wrong getting tiny
things right that are so often done
wrong can endear a film to a group of
people now I don't have statistics on
what I'm about to say but anecdotal
evidence
I do have I've met a couple of lawyers
who really love my cousin Vinnie not
because or not just because it's a great
movie but because it might well be the
single most accurate depiction of the
trial process that's been put to film it
includes so many of the details every
other law film you know just glosses
over or flatly gets wrong similarly
Edgar Wright has said that after the
release of his film Hot Fuzz he's been
told a number of times by police
officers how much they appreciated the
depiction of paperwork in the film
police paperwork rarely gets more than a
one-off mention in most cop films
usually it's a it's a joke about how
much there's gonna be after you know the
end of the adventure but you know it
never gets shown and Hot Fuzz paperwork
is lingered on it's brought up
repeatedly in the end in a way that
police officers hadn't seen before on
film and they appreciated that but and
here comes the crutch of the thought
experiment for a moment try to imagine
that the thing about yourself that you
never see reflected on-screen isn't a
career or where you live but a
fundamental deep-seated truth about your
very existence in the case of lgbtq+
people it's an aspect of yourself that
portions of society are already telling
you is wrong or evil or is a sickness
when almost none of the entertainment
you consume acknowledges your very
existence as an lgbtq+ person much less
your normalcy well you feel wrong you
feel isolated you feel alone and the
thing
when I say representation matters I mean
mainstream representation because
another thing that gets brought up in
these conversations is why do we need
representation for groups like the
lgbtq+ community in mainstream movies
why can't they have their own things
made just for them well firstly we do
have that Gail it queer films they're
thriving subgenres they have been for
years and while the existence of these
specialized markets is no bad thing it
doesn't really help in the way that I'm
talking about because it still separates
us from society at large the very idea
of mainstream entertainment is that it's
intended to appeal and speak to the
broadest possible audience and if you
see yourself reflected in niche product
but rarely if ever in the mainstream
that sends a message it says you are not
like the rest of us or if you're
somebody already feeling isolated or
confused that message might even come
across harsher more like you're not
welcome here
our absence becomes a statement in and
of itself and a statement that a
fictional world doesn't have a place for
queer people is an implicit statement
about society as a whole when that
fictional world is intended to appeal to
as many people as possible the takeaway
is that we don't count and the people
who do count don't want to see us this
kind of thing it eats at you over time
and it has a long-term cumulative effect
on both society as a whole and
individuals because pop culture is a big
part of how most of us perceive the
world beyond our own personal day-to-day
experiences when we lack first-hand
experience in certain areas be it
certain living conditions certain kinds
of flights joists ways of thought
sexualities
we gravitate towards other sources
secondary sources to shape our feelings
about those things pop culture isn't the
only source on this do be clear news
media is a big one as well and there are
others but I'm not about to try and
parse out which is the bigger shape of a
shaper of our outlooks and I'm pretty
sure it's kind of a case-by-case thing
anyways if we could just accept that pop
culture is at play in this which I don't
think is something that's in dispute so
if there's a real-world element
environment or kind of person that we
only ever encounter in fiction but not
in our day to day lives that fiction is
going to shape how we feel about that
thing place or person now even if we
know and understand you know
intellectually that it's fiction it's
not fact that still forms a foundation
it's the starting point that future
information and experiences is going to
end up getting filtered through and if
representation is absent or so rare that
each instance is really notable it
creates a starting point of this is
weird why is that there so if you're not
LGBTQ TQ plus it can mean that you
default to thinking of us as aberrations
because your window to the world outside
of your immediate experience rarely if
ever depicts us and if it does your
instinct becomes the question why is it
there
meanwhile if you are LGBTQ plus yourself
this means that there's an adverse
effect on your sense of places and
acceptance both within the world you
live and sometimes within yourself it's
worth noting that sometimes even those
of us who are are in fact
underrepresented don't fully comprehend
what this does to us I'm gonna do
something I don't normally do I'm
actually gonna share a clip from another
youtuber um and this is a moment of
clarity
that she shared that I think ties into
this this is from the channel NYX fears
which is run by a trans woman
May and the clip I'm about to show
describes the experience she had seeing
a trans character played by a trans
actress in a way that spoke to her own
experiences when she watched the film
assassination nation I was connecting
with this character on screen more than
I'd maybe ever connected with the
character and in that moment it was like
all that sort of representative ideas
you know about characters representing
something larger than that on screen and
how those things can mean something to
us beyond our own sort of preconceptions
it all kind of hit me and I actually had
a pretty profound experience it gets on
the holiest because holy [ __ ] I didn't
know I could feel that way and like I've
gone the majority of my life without
feeling that way when I connect to
people on-screen and it's actually been
like sort of a this distancing
experience there was something she said
that really grabbed me immediately
the first time I saw that video I didn't
know I could feel that way May's an
intelligent woman I have no doubt that
she understood the issues with a lack of
representation on an intellectual level
but it wasn't until she saw that film
and had that experience a feeling
properly represented for the first time
that it truly hit her what she'd been
missing for her entire movie watching a
life this is how powerful representation
can be when it's experienced by those
who don't have it and as profound as
that experience was for her I think it
also helps illustrate and it kind of
roundabout way another reason why
representation needs to be main stream
because chances are you folks didn't see
assassination nation you probably didn't
even hear of it it was not a mainstream
hit it didn't get a wide release but it
also had a very limited marketing
campaign and ultimately it didn't even
recoup it's rather paltry seven million
dollar budget people didn't see it most
people didn't know about it and it
didn't seem like the studio was really
expecting them to it was a niche
product but when representation is
present in truly mainstream media it
increases the possibility for the people
who need to see it actually will for
them and the populace at large it
increases the sense that they are not
some bizarre outlying strange and
unknowable thing but just another part
of the world it's a world we're watching
on a screen yes but when it happens on
enough screens it can make the real
world feel a little less hostile for
those who can't help but sense and be
aware of their own other necessitate
matters first so many reasons the
hardest thing about being part of any
marginalized group is the sense of
isolation that comes with that and the
lgbtq+ populace has that factor
inherently amplified by the fact that
until you go out of your way to seek it
out if you're even able to do so there's
no guarantee that you'll encounter a
single other person like yourself in
your day-to-day life even within your
own family members of say a racial
minority they're usually able to at
least look at their immediate family
mothers fathers siblings and see the
thing that makes them a minority in this
country reflected back to them by at
least a few people lgbtq+ people don't
have that or at least it's less of a
certainty and I don't I don't want to
compare or rank the hardships of one
group against another but it's a factor
for us which adds to that sense of
isolation or just flat-out feeling wrong
an lgbtq+ person can't tune into a TV
show or a movie and see somebody on
there that speaks to that part of them
and to see a character simply existing
like it's a normal life but if they can
if they do see that that can be a
lifeline it is a
tiny reassurance that maybe you're not a
monster and that there's a place for you
but if you go to the movies and turn on
the TV and you take in the entertainment
that you know most of the country is
watching and enjoying and you don't see
yourself anywhere on an action movies
not in sci-fi adventures not in epic
fantasies and not among the superheroes
that possibly reinforces every depth you
have about your own existence that you
are so alone or so much of an aberration
that even in films as detached from
reality as those showing people flying
around in capes there's no point in
representing you there is no place for
you that there's nothing to do but
retreat into a corner where you won't
bother anyone
and that corner can become a hole and
that hole can become a pit and not
everybody can climb out of their pit
this is not the experience of every
lgbtq+ person but is the experience of
many of us and hopefully I've been able
to shed some light on how it can feel
when you're an lgbtq+ person in a world
where it's just so dicey that that ever
gets shown in the mainstream I mean
think about it whatever it happens it
makes headlines that's how rare it is
and unless you believe I'm just lying
about how this feels
then I hope maybe you understand a
little bit better the potential and
vital good the representation can do if
you want to question the value of a
specific depiction that's a conversation
I'm more than happy to engage in but I
don't have the strength to keep
justifying my presence my mere existence
not in the fictional world
not in real life we're here we exist and
knowing that the world realizes that is
what keeps some of us going
representation is hard it's hard to do
right and it can sometimes feel like
when you try and represent a group all
they do is pick at what it is you're
doing but another part of that is
there's so few instances of
representation of us how can we not pick
at it you don't see people picking at
every single problematic representation
of this white male I mean some people do
but it's not the standard conversation
that happens because there's so many
instances of sis white male straight
heroes that if this one isn't to your
liking there's a bajillion others for
you to take in we don't have that so I
know I get nitpicky and I know I can get
upset with the representation that does
happen but I don't want that to ever
make it seem like it's not worth it
because representation matters and if it
doesn't exist at all then it can't get
better because you can't fix something
that simply isn't there so that's my
little treatise on why representation as
a thing is important thank you for
listening if you enjoyed this video I
would encourage you to check out the
patreon I'm hoping to do more in depth
videos not necessarily on this subject
matter I mean I do this monthly but not
necessarily more videos on just the
subject matter but I'm trying to find
the time and the means to get more
in-depth into things and the patreon is
a big help towards that there's other
links down there beside
I'm on social media all that sort of
stuff I have a book that is relevant to
this part of my life there's a link for
that so you can look at all that but you
don't have to because if you're this far
into the video then you listened and
thank you for that so whatever your
thoughts on whatever I've said are drop
them down the comments respectfully
please and we'll talk about it so until
the next video please remember you are
valid you are loved you are welcome on
this council and until the next time the
Council of geeks is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]